[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
good morning it's sunday and a great day
to watch football welcome to the squad
ride presented by draftkings live in the
bleacher report app
unlike daniel jones we're not going to
trip and fall on our way to giving out
free hoodies my name is cabbie richards
alongside the captain and our mvp and
betting expert kelly stewart
and when this man is not taking side
bets in a batting cage he's taking your
bets on the football field that is greg
ivory our squad
we bet anytime touchdown locks suggested
by you
the legends that watch this show we're
foreign to you this season and we need
to keep it going
earlier this week we asked you who's a
lock to score a touchdown in week seven
these are some of the most popular picks
that you sent us
well there's kareem hunt playing
cincinnati today josh jacobs
sighting play in tampa we got a great
list of studs here we've narrowed it
down to five
legendary videos that we're going to
show you and you're going to decide our
week 7 squad ride
okay listen the gauntlet has been thrown
down this week okay you guys have sent
us some legendary videos
and it all started with our very own
mikey locks
take a look
biggest moment of our lives i love you
good luck to us
three two
absolute hammerlock to score this
psyching out the whole fam for a lock by
dude
that is so risky that's the kind of
dedication we're looking forward you
send us your video so
where do the wise be better than mike i
mean we work with them it's easy to do
but uh
great video man great video
mike is a legend mike is a legend but
cabbie
mikey's a legend let me get into these
legendary comments because you know what
i want to do
you kelly you know what i want to do too
the comments knows what i want to do
and look i actually got an upgrade i'm
not on my phone
anymore i got a handy dandy ipod i'm
ready to take all types of takes that's
cause you listen to me with that niners
money line last
uh sunday afternoon hey you know you
know the deal kelly you know the deal
let me take out my handy dandy
pin and uh let me get into this let me
get into some comments
i'm only giving away comments i got in
trouble last week i'm only giving away
comments for
i mean i'm only giving away hoodies for
good comments okay for good comments so
good takes i got um
i got stone cold 84 says the under for
the the washington football team cowboys
rain all day easy money okay
i was talking to my buddies about that
so i'm gonna give
stone cold 84 hoodie you're walking away
with a hoodie for the take
uh chai town bears 32 says
le michael p ryan will fill in for
le'veon bell with the touchdown
kelly what's your take is that deserving
of a hoodie
uh listen p ryan should be starting for
le'veon i get it
i don't know if he's going to score a
touchdown this is going to be tough
this is going to be he's i think his
first name is lamichael
we're going to get into bill's job
but but let's get to round one let's get
around with our first pitch
comes from flugassi and his mom
i already
let's go
okay terry mclaren okay excellent
excellent okay kels
and greg one second we got to get to the
the opponent flugassi's opponent in this
round
is jordan diddy and oddly enough
the papa
this is how we make picks here at papa
john's we put toppings on the pizza put
it in the oven
whatever initials come out on the pizza
that is the luck let's see what it is
this week
derek here lock it up
oh that man is a legend yo batman is a
legend yo
yo yo that man is an absolutely i've
never seen this before i've never
seen this before we got pizza olives
derrick henry creativity legendary
status but also gotta
show some love to the to the mom legend
i mean she did give him a pic
she gave him a pic cabbie he asked his
mom
she delivered with a pic so what do you
think ellie
mccoran or derek henry
i want kelly to actually tell me kelly
tell me mclaren
henry pizza mom talk to me
i mean my mom would just leave me left
on red so
props to his mom for actually answering
him uh
look i i have to go with the pizza
legend look
we have derek henry the best running
back in the league i don't care
don't act me now they are going against
the second best rushing defense in the
league that makes me a little nervous
but if you want to give me the odds
boost
tell me you're gonna give me three to
one on derek henry i i wanna say i like
the
the papa legend but olives come on my
dude
why can't he was like something good
like pepperoni
and and what do you think about alice
versus washington kels
you know this one's top caps with with
regards to this game
i think that you could have teased each
side depending on who was the favorite
i think divisional home dogs are
something that i love
to get on board with they're 5-0 this
year
at home we know that washington football
team has shown some moments of greatness
at minus one a lean towards washington
uh i don't love this game oh okay
cabbie i still made my nose abby cabbie
yes g money cabbie as you are making
your notes as you are making your notes
i'm also documenting my notes
into these comments i got sloan 58
saying uh henry flat mortal kombat
stiffing arming people
is always legendary guess what sloane 58
that comment was legendary and that was
also a good take so you're walking away
with a hoodie
uh i got um marky mark
975 stefan
diggs is is as big of a lock as td as
gregor claus is giving
my guy marky mark knows the deal
stefan dicks okay i like that pick just
because he said that cabbie i'm gonna
give him a hoodie
uh cabbie i am i think we have to
decide a winner here i'm seeing a lot
and i mean a lot of
derrick henry popple john legend
uh cabbie we have to move on
with derrick henry and the papa john
legend okay
the fans have decided the fans have
decided yes and we
and we also need to give an r.i.p to
josh norman who was on the receiving end
of that vicious stiff arm
a few weeks ago so congrats to jordan
diddy you are you've made it through
round one there are three
three more rounds to go so let's lock in
for round two our next pitch is from the
mayor
audience you let us know if the mayor is
going to knock off our papa legend
and jordan jordan diddy
get in the comments tell us who you got
the mayor who do you got
[Music]
baby i know you love me but if you were
to date another man
would you would you like him more if his
name was korean
or derek or stefan
kareem derek or stefan probably staphon
stefan you like daddy diggs you gonna
score a touchdown this weekend
i don't know it's daddy diggs
that is very dangerous that is very
dangerous the love is there i can i can
sense the love is there but one thing
one thing that i that i sense that's not
there is
the the they're they're just not
connected they're
i don't i don't know the chemistry
she said it wouldn't feel that way great
yes it was definitely to leave me alone
the chemistry
between the two wasn't there but let me
tell you who
chemistry is on one accord josh
allen and stefan diggs they have been
hooking
up this season scoring an abundance of
touchdowns um
kelly please talk to me stefan diggs
henry leave me alone papa john's legend
what are we thinking i feel her on this
one leave me alone about this
dumb game it's the jets man this has
been
the biggest conundrum of the week right
so the bill's open 10
it moves to 12 and a half now mind you
that's not a big money move there's no
real key numbers there
i said look give me like 14 and a half
and i'll take the jets fine at home
against a divisional rival and then
some very famous sharp better came in
and bet the
jets at 12 and a half and now it's back
to 10. i want nothing to do with this
game greg i want nothing to do with it
i'm not going to watch it
uh stefan diggs of course he should
against that
jet secondary be able to score a
touchdown as you mentioned him and josh
allen have a great chemistry
sorry leave me alone i got to leave this
one alone nice
there's just no touching it here so
t-money who have the audience rocking
with are they leaving the jets and the
bills alone and staphon digs are they or
are they rocking with derrick henry and
our papa legend
before before we move on just let me
give away some hoodies
i'm still calculating uh some totals i
got uh
i got i love ranch he's talking about
the jets the
jets why are we even talking about the
i'll just tell you guys what he says he
says no
chemistry just like the jets i mean i do
agree with you the jets don't have
chemistry they didn't have a lot of
chemistry
you're walking away with a hoodie i do
not like ranch but i love your
your your username here we go cabbage
guy
no no sauce only
barbecue sauce only hold on cabbie i'm
still in the comments yeah
sports feeds saying henry stiff arms
digs in
in this head to head i like that and
guess what and guess what
sports feeds you're walking away with a
hoodie and in this head-to-head because
you guys are coming in
and my handy-dandy pin is telling me
that
papa john's legend and derek henry is
moving on to the next round cabbie oh
wow okay listen jordan diddy congrats
you're still the big dog on top of the
hill to kelly's point earlier derek
henry is the nfl's leading rusher so
solid pick my dude that's two naropa you
have two left
to conquer so our next pitch comes from
colby cook
and his best friend this is kryptonite
all right leave it all up to the dog for
this hoodie
we got aaron jones we got derrick henry
kareem hunt devante adams
stefan diggs and mylock alvin kamara
two wide receivers out he's bound to get
a touchdown
who's it gonna be lucy
come on going for alvin
kamara lock of the week i told you he
ain't got two wide receivers
it's show time baby let's go new orleans
state's luck of the week
lucy's a good girl that's no cabbie
that's why i said it was cryptic no
cabbie
good girl yeah now cabbie that's what i
call
chemistry that is what i call chemistry
between the two
my guy the air i mean lucy lucy lucy
does an
awesome job uh she looks like air bud a
little bit took me back to my childhood
days but she does an awesome job
of of of thinking about it and making a
commitment and she committed to
the pick that her owner wanted to pick
i'm loving i'm loving
loving loving the chemistry there kelly
now talk to me about the pic
we got alvin kamara derek henry we got
chemistry we got
legendary status of papa john's pizza
talk to me
what are you thinking kelly i love these
ugcs you guys have really stepped it up
i need more dogs in my life so keep
those videos coming
i can't tell you guys about this game
because it's part of my best
bet needless to say
i'll i won't say anymore cavea will get
mad if i give out spoiler alert
alec amara is a great pick he's leading
the nfl in touchdowns with seven so
we're gonna save the juicier bits um for
down uh for later in the show
um greg how is that how's the audience
reacting to lucy
and colby cook's pick of kamara or are
they still rocking with our papa legend
and his derek henry pick a few rounds
ago
cabbie i'm seeing a lot of love for lucy
i don't know about the kamara pic but i
do see a lot of love
for lucy riles232
says that pup knows what's up so guess
what i'm gonna know what's up
and i'm gonna send you a hoodie riles uh
i got that puppy is better than half of
the jets offense that's i love randy's
back at it
i'm not i'm i'm not gonna give you a
hoodie again
i love ranch but uh
tanika planned 88 camaro will hurtle
henry stifform i don't know about that
one cabbie
there there's a mixture there's a
mixture but but i'm gonna make a call
here
i'm gonna go to my pin and i'm just
gonna scroll and whatever i land on
that's what we're gonna ride with
because there's a picture between the
two
you guys ready we're splitting one
we're rocking with papa john's legend
and derrick henry
the pit it wasn't me it was the pin
don't blame me
blame the pin it's a it's a big time
pick and this has never happened before
we are like
jordan diddy has won three straight
rounds and we're about to enter the
final round so that's who we're rocking
with that's who the audience is rocking
with
jordan diddy the popularity the papa
legend
is moving on my god the papa legend is
moving this is legendary he's running
through the whole show
he's running through the whole show like
derrick henry runs through the secondary
okay so this is our final
the winner of this matchup will
determine our squad ride and we always
ride
with who the audience rocks with so our
final pitch comes from
ao it's jeff tell us who we should ride
with
[Music]
cream height the lock
that would be different to me that one
hit different
i knew there was going to be some
canadian bias with this one cabbie
i'm like blown away i'm i'm blown away
like it was so cinnamon i thought i was
watching the movie cinematic he had the
music
you know he even acted in his own
production like
you know he's giving us a little tyler
perry you know i mean but anyway
anyway we saw we saw the video
kelly we saw the video now talk to us
about the pick
kareem hunt he's playing cincinnati
today derek henry he's playing
pittsburgh we got papa john legend the
legend himself he's ran through the
whole field
against the cinematic knuckle puck
legend oh
shout out keenan thompson uh and kareem
hunt kelly tell us tell us tell us what
are you thinking
you know this one's interesting because
i've been preaching about these
divisional
dogs and i leaned towards the bengals i
didn't get to the window with them but i
kind of have a bias here i have kareem
hunt on my fantasy team
and this dude only scored me seven
points last week
i'm kind of leaning towards my knuckle
puck guy out of vancouver
this is just tough i'm like in this like
glass case of emotion
i got the steelers in a teaser i lean
towards the titans now
later on in the week oh why'd you have
to put olives on the pizza my dude you
could have sold me with the pepperoni
uh i gotta i gotta go with the better
running back here greg bottom line
is derek henry if i'm forced to pick
papa john's dude
nice we're not sure exactly where jeff
is from but we think it's vancouver
because there's some puddles on
on the ground and yes that that brought
like you said greg
the mighty ducks keenan thompson mighty
ducks air that that
hit the feels for me as well so get in
the comments let us know if it hits you
in the fields
vote for our winner we have the papa
john legend and jordan diddy
and derek henry or ao it's jeff kareem
hunt
for the browns versus cincinnati today
in the meantime
in between time kelly kells this is your
moment to shine
give the people your best bet in week
seven
kathy let's do this we need a little bit
of a bounce back have you guys been
watching the ig videos that our
awesome social team puts up on saturday
we've been doing well
these best bets man i swear we have been
cursed but i feel really good about this
one why because the reverse
line movement is on our side that means
all the money is opposite of all the
tickets that's why we saw
the panthers come from eight down and
now six and a half with our friends
over at draftkings i locked this in on
wednesday at seven and a half
but i still feel really good about teddy
bridgewater's return
to new orleans now if you guys remember
he was drew brees's backup
now excuse me a man named
jameis winston i think teddy has
superseded expectations i'm really happy
with
the job that matt rules done in carolina
especially without
their star running back so i like
carolina here
this divisional road dog they have been
cashing tickets for us all year
carolina and don't forget to sprinkle a
little bit on that money line
if you're on draftkings lock in that
wager if you're rocking with teddy
bridgewater
mike davis and our mvp kelly stewart
well done
i'm about to lock in as soon as as soon
as we finish the stream
greg we are ready to stack some stacks
90 minutes before kickoff so let us know
my g
who are we riding with and who is our
new legend
the squad ride give it to us in week 7.
you guys sure you ready well i'm ready
my dude got my phone here
i'm ready to lock in all right brother
let me see let me pull out my handy
danny i mean it was already pulled out
my panty dandy pin
and roll through these comments i got uh
d style saying henry is lit yes yes yes
i got uh swiggity 13
saying hunt cabbie it's a back and forth
match up uh in the comments
but the next one i see i'm just gonna
ride with it
next one i see i got henry
derek henry i'm yeah it's derek henry
i've seen a lot of derrick henry
i'm i'm just calling it yeah i'm calling
it how i see it okay a lot of derrick
henry in the comments
a lot of papa john's rocking with
derrick henry give me the graphic please
change it please to plus 300 because our
guys from draftking
that's what they do for us they only do
that for us
gabby you know that right yeah they only
do that for us it's exclusive
it's exclusive to us yes yes yes
cabbie are you badness one thousand
percent yo shout out to you jordan diddy
the papa legend for giving us that derek
henry pick
well done can't wait to watch the titans
and the steelers today
um so check out br betting social for
the link
to the odds boost that's very important
send us your screenshots that's also
very important we love seeing them we
love winners we want winners
we embrace winners and you guys have
been sharing a bunch of them with us
um and and send us your videos too
you've seen like you know that the the
game has been stepped up so
continue to step up your game and stay
creative uh greg
we've reached the end of the show and i
know you're going to interrupt me anyway
to give away some more hoodies
so while you just get to it
slow switch up i got you right here
cabbie a handsome
duck that's that's his username that
that's using it t
higgins top player this week yes i love
t higgins he's actually starting on my
fantasy team
you're walking away with a hoodie k
burke us45
henry like a stiff arm from kelly kelly
is strong
she does have that ah stiff arm uh
you're walking away that's what she does
everybody on twitter
it's a stiff arm heisman poses stiff arm
all day hey sjr1434
another week and still no hoodie brother
brother brother
relax greg across is here
and with the last hoodie of the day i'm
giving it to my guy
you're not going another week without a
hoodie because greg is here you're so
generous i am the beer i love you yes
yes yes
cabbie let's let's let's let's take it
all home man let's take it off listen
thank you to everybody who commented
thank you to our new legends jordan
diddy the papa legend flugassi the mayor
colby cook and lucy
and ayo it's jeff keep working on the
wrist shot my dude
alongside kelly stewart greg ivory my
name is cabbie richard see you guys next
week
here are some of last week's locks and
best reactions
to take us out good luck and we're
riding with derek henry baby
the squad ride let's go get it
what up bleach your report what up with
your point what'd i be our betting
i love you i love you i love you
my pick for this week's anytime tv score
of the week is kyler murray
my pick is lamar jackson believe
madison's gonna score a touchdown
[Music]
yes
[Music]
you